I need your feedback so one of the
things that have been experimenting with
on the channel for the past number of
months has been putting in lower thirds
on the videos and you'll see these on
the ends Presto's and you'll see this on
the top 10 we're at the bottom of the
video while somebody's talking if we
have a famous entrepreneur on we share a
little bit of information on them will
show their picture and we'll show you
know three to five lines at you for the
top ten they'll be a little more we won
per video but a little bit more context
about who the person is while they're
talking and it's commonly done on TV and
I thought this would be a cool
experiment to put into the youtube
channel and I'm wondering if you guys
get value from it I'm wondering if it's
worth the investment because it takes us
time right it takes Ivan my researcher
time to find the sentences and I have to
review them and approve them that
christina has to edit them in and they
fly in and out and that's all work and
if it if it adds value to you guys then
I'm totally happy to keep doing it if
you just like me I could live with it
but I don't care either either way right
then I'm probably gonna spend time in it
so I'm really curious to know what you
guys think about our lower thirds or if
you have some other suggestions how we
may be able to use that space better
leaving the comments below really
curious to find out and we're going to
take action based on what you guys say
so leave a comment because I really care
so thank you guys for watching let me
know you think in the comments continue
to believe and I'll see you soon